[Music]
Jenna Maroney
you're my slave what but the shiku on me
in that poker game was beheaded no do
you remember in 1994 you made a
commercial for Serge Cola for 100 surge
points I got the shade oh yeah for 500
surge points I got this leather jacket I
could beat that
for a million points he got me search
so I remember that my boyfriend was
supposed to pick me up after that shoot
so I called him and I was like OJ where
are you and he was like wait you're
alive then who did I kill
foreign
what's wrong my niece drew a picture of
me and I look so fat
well I really like your hair today thank
you thank you but you don't know what it
is like
oh she finally figured that out this is
Manhattan real estate there are no rules
like check-in on an Italian sex party I
mean you know how long I've been waiting
for the lady next door to finally join
her husband in hell
hello Mrs gerstein oh
God is getting stronger every day you
ancient you've already got a foot
in the door here's what you're gonna do
do you remember that horrible roommate
you had back in Chicago you mean you I
know it's my turn to do the dishes but
I'm in character and if you make me do
the dishes I will kill myself
you drove a lot of guys out of that
third bedroom
Jack is hiring a new cast member
oh don't be so dramatic that's my thing
and if you take it away from me I will
kill myself and then you
okay Jenna I need some relationship
advice while you've come to the right
place I've been writing a sex column for
Cosmo Cosmo is my 14 year old neighbor
he doesn't know anything no it's not
about sex
it's about money oh Liz sex money power
fire choking being dragged behind a
speedboat it's all the same thing are
you kidding me remember when Jenna
thought that blonde intern wanted to be
an actress
I'm studying acting and singing and
Someday I'm gonna be just like you
find her earlobe
Jenna's crab but idiots won't shut up
why couldn't she have died when that
rabid dog bit her oh it wasn't rabid I
just said that so they'd have to put it
down and then I'd be the star of that
dog food commercial I had to walk an
extra block to get around your stupid
Crab Catchers my doctors have been very
clear about this Jenna if I get moderate
exercise I'm gonna die and I'm mad it's
just success but pretending it's
something else okay speaking of me
how many Crab Catchers Fiesta crab hats
would each of you like to buy at the
unbelievable price of 49.95 please I've
had a crab on my head for free
I'm lying the claws hold your cigarette
while you uncook a bruise guy on cork of
Bruce guy yeah you know because that
Blinky Blinky Blinky blink those aren't
even the right noises everyone knows you
hate stuff like this you're maybe the
most high maintenance in Hollywood
maybe who's more who is she do you need
a sex tape released because I got a
weird one it's night vision and you can
see that his buddy is robbing me OMG Liz
look at you and me and our biological
clocks you're going baby crazy and I
keep getting turned on by car accidents
Ron that was terrible I'm gonna be
constructive here you should kill
yourself
being dead is the best thing that ever
happened in this movie
fine but I have to pee first no no no no
no no Tupac Shakur the rapper he sold 10
times more albums when he was dead than
when he was alive that's what we're
going to do with this movie Die Young
become a legend just like Janice or
Rusty the bear from the magicals
yes now you just need to stay dead while
I saw the movie oh I can play dead I
watched my whole church group get eaten
by a bear no Terry I suspect you know
it's illegal for someone to own another
human being fine but according to the
contest rules either I collect my prize
or her equivalent cash value ah I see so
you'll be just as happy with the money
Terry is this true I've done the math
and taking into account Jenna's salary
and earning potential I've calculated
that she's worth
eight hundred thousand dollars
uh let's say Jenna was worth that in her
prime that was 10 years ago
she has certainly depreciated since then
Jenna is becoming more unemployable by
the moment and thanks to Decades of
partying Jenna's internal organs will
get you nothing on the black market
she's an emotional train wreck why are
you doing this seventh grade education
hepatitis D bullet and jaw fatwa credit
card debt wanted by the Yakuza Jenna
Maroney is worth
two thousand dollars fine
in Arizona too Grand will buy me a
castle and a pillowcase full of Meth
I could add to Doomsday Enterprises
[Music]
said about you and I just have to say
that I have known Liz a long long long
time and she's totally Shady
see oh my God you are hilarious
do you act because we should do a movie
together where we're on a road trip just
being
high five
[Music]
oh no someone's gonna get more attention
than me Frank Frank Frank
what is this future husband who did you
put in your address book as future
husband I have absolutely no idea well
whenever I find something weird in my
cell phone I can usually trace it back
to the last time I was drunk oh my God
the dentist's office oh your dentist
gets drunk with you too no it's me
as great as I am at this I'm not really
necessary
hmm the last time I said that I was in a
three-way with two of the Backstreet
Boys
you missed a call was it my doctor slash
trainer no it was Dennis Dennis Duffy
calling me
why well Jenna Dennis has been going
around calling all the women he's ever
had sex with
did you speak to him yes did you pretend
to be me I did did you do an impression
of me was it British it was oh my God
Liz first of all the reason I have some
English inflection in my speech is
because I lost my virginity to the my
fair lady soundtrack and I definitely
would have gone to my reunion but the
boat I was educated on sank I want to
thank the brilliant Kevin Grisham The
Amazing John Stamos the incomparable
Judge Judy Sheindlin what are you doing
they called my name
see you later suckers meet me
[Music]
well my armpit rashes back oh my God
Jack what are you doing in wardrobe
latest researchers in our audience
doesn't like green oh that's too bad I
like green research doesn't lie Jenna
lets us know what we're thinking
it's boring what's too gay what's too
old what's too old that's a very good
question how old are you I'm 29 what
year were you born 1977 when did you
graduate high school 94 when you turn 40
2017 Junior High Crush Kurt Cameron prom
theme Motown Philly Boys to Men what
movie did you lose your virginity at
Arachnophobia theater or Drive-In
what's the drive-in
I don't know why I bothered to ask I can
tell just from your physical appearance
that you're obviously
the writers can't take a car service at
night anymore I've crunched the numbers
and it's cheaper for us to just replace
anyone who gets murdered
amazing news Liz I made the People
Magazine crossword one across five
letters Jenna maroney's first name wow
congratulations because of America's
kids got singing I am blowing up when
you Google Jenna Maroney now I come up
first not the Jenna Maroney who
electrocuted all those horses Jenna that
was you you will never believe what just
happened to me I was throwing a tantrum
in the makeup room
I will have you pre-inspired I will tell
the other days your real ages I'll be
ignored by my friends no one paid any
attention to stop ignoring me this is an
actor announcement the show's over so
you're not technically an actor anymore
how dare you you rotting pair I will
stop being an actress when the earth
stops spinning on Kabbalah Monster's
fingernail the only thing that's
stopping is this show it's beneath me
and from now on Jenna Maroney only plays
dramatic roles goodbye forever you
factory reject dildos
[Music]